il s'appelle atchoum nez et spider man
et tous les trois se font une sortie au
centre commercial c'est samedi du mois
de septembre
leur mission faire découvrir leur
univers aux plus petits c'est un sport
de plein air
il apprend à l'enfant à être altruiste
puisqu'il va vraiment s'occuper d'un
animal vivant
il ya un contact avec l'animal que les
autres sports non pas forcément
et c'est ça qui est très important la
nature l'animal et le le don de soi un
peu les enfants apprendront comment on
s'occupe du poney de sa nourriture
jusqu'au passage le club sky équitation
accueil des petits dès l'âge de 2 ans
pour des cours hebdomadaires mais
également des stages ponctuels pendant
les vacances je trouve que c'est très
bien pour faire découvrir un petit peu
l'univers
du poney d'équitation aux enfants c'est
une bonne première approche
c'est plutôt sympa pouvoir venir voir
les poneys pendant qu'on fait un petit
tour avec les petits et pouvoir
découvrir un petit peu tout ça après les
explications la balade dans les allées
de l'espace saint quentin et pour les
plus petits un parcours rien que pour
eux sur des poneys
parfois aussi capricieux que les vrais